as you come in i'll start to welcome you
i'm paul north
and these are the frankie lectures in
the humanities at the whitney humanities
center this is a series called the value
of marx's capital
which i'm convening along with my
co-conspirator paul writer at ohio state
who is the
valiant translator of a new translation
of
volume one into english
the series is also a companion to a an
undergraduate seminar
so the undergrads have valiantly gone
through volume one
with a kind of a microscope
they've survived and if they have
survived there in the audience tonight
i have to read this the frankie lectures
are made possible by the generosity of
richard and barbara frankie
and are intended to present important
topics in the humanities to a wide and
general audience
i need to thank as i always do alice
kaplan the director of the whitney
humanities center
sandra mullan bowles and lyanna
hirschfeld crowen
who have done behind the scenes
organizing and audrey leake who is our
tech
genius making things stay on track
i know a lot of you have been here so
you've heard this before we will have
the presentation from our speaker
then tonight we're going to have a short
response by
our friend and another co-conspirator
mikhail heinrich who's back to discuss a
little bit with
fred mosley and then we'll open to
questions hold your questions and put
them into the chat
when we get to that period otherwise i
will lose them
and doing my best to keep everybody
in order it is a great pleasure to
introduce fred mosley
who is an emeritus professor of
economics at mount holyoke
college where he taught marx
and marxian economic theory for many
years
he has published extensively on marxian
theory
and the marxian analysis of the u.s
economy
his latest book is money and totality a
macro monetary interpretation of marx's
logic and capital
and the end of the transformation
problem we can celebrate that that was
from 2016.
he also edited and wrote the
introduction to the english translation
of marx's economic manuscript
of 1864-65 these are the manuscripts
that are newly translated into english
that became volume 3
of capital edited by engels
he's a long-time member of the union for
radical political economics
and served as program director for the
urpe sessions
at the annual convention of the american
economic association
for 10 years i'd like to welcome fred
mosley
fred i'm going to give the microphone
over to you
well thank you very much paul and uh
thank you for the invitation to
participate
in this very uh interesting
[Music]
and innovative i think
seminar i've watched some of the other
sessions
and it's been
really uh an inspiration to hear the
different perspectives
on uh on volume one
um thanks also to the
the the whitney foundation for the
generous funding
uh or this seminar that uh is
really uh quite a contribution
uh both uh the the
the the theory and the pedagogy i think
uh of
uh marxian theory
well uh the the paper i'm gonna present
tonight is different
from the my original intention and the
one i sent to paul
in september just to explain a little
bit uh that paper
uh was an overview of all of volume one
uh with a focus on these two important
uh aspects that i discussed in my recent
book
uh the monetary nature of marxist theory
and volume one
and the macro uh nature of
uh volume one uh mainly explaining the
total surplus value
uh in the economy as a whole um
however uh uh listening to the
presentation
by my old friend michael heinrich um
in his presentation in the seminar i
thought i would add a few comments uh
to uh my paper and then i kept
adding uh more and more comments
eventually i had a whole new paper uh
obviously very stimulated by
mikhail's uh opportunity to
engage again with nikhil and i decided i
would discuss this new paper
uh in my presentation um
both because that's what i'm most
interested in at the moment and i also
hope you will be uh
be more interesting to participants to
dig deep
into the all-important chapter one and
to consider these two somewhat different
interpretations
this important chapter if some of you
may have read the other paper and have
questions about that i would of course
be happy to discuss
and let me say even though mikhail and i
disagree
uh about uh some aspects
of uh interpretation of marx's theory of
value and money
in chapter one i want to say at the
outset how much i appreciate
mikhail's uh contribution uh
to uh marxian scholarship and how much i
have learned from him
especially about the mecca i first
learned about the mega
uh from mikhail in the early 90s uh
from a 1989 paper he published in
capital in class
uh about the manuscript of 1861-63
published for the first time in the mega
in the 80s
and almost unknown at the time among
english-speaking marxists and i was very
excited
including myself so i was very excited
to learn about the mega and
much of my research since then has been
related to the mega in one way or
another
so for me uh and for many other
english-speaking
and german challenged uh marxist
uh mikhail uh has been a very important
kind of conduit uh from
the german marxian scholarship and
especially
uh the mega uh to uh anglo
marxist which i appreciate very much
you could say today maybe mikhail has
been a sort of
super spread uh of
uh in in the good sense of the term uh
of uh german marxian scholarship
so my talk will focus on chapter one and
uh um by all accounts chapter one
is a very difficult chapter uh and for
that reason
uh very controversial yeah
um mark said in the preface to the first
edition
as you remember beginnings are always
difficult
in all sciences the understanding of the
first chapter will therefore present the
greatest difficulty
i have popularized he says uh the
passages concerning the substance of
value
and the magnitude of value as much as
possible
and the section in the form of value is
the most difficult
my favorite preface actually the volume
one is to the french edition
i don't know if you've noticed this or
not um
but he says the method of analysis which
i have employed
and which had not previously been
applied to economic subjects
makes the reading of the first chapter
rather arduous
and it is to be feared that the french
public
substitute the american public always
impatient to come to a conclusion eager
to know the connection between the
general principles
and the immediate questions that have
aroused their passions
may be disheartened uh because they
cannot move on
uh at once mark says this is a
disadvantage i am
powerless to overcome unless it be by
forewarning
and for arming those readers who
zealously
seek the truth there's no royal road to
science
no easy road to science and only those
who do not dread
the fatiguing climb of its steep pass
have a chance of gaining its luminous
summers
so you probably have found chapter one
to be a fatiguing climb uh
and i hope uh there will also be some
luminous sounds
um so first i want to briefly describe
the overall logical structure of chapter
one
uh that marx alluded to in these
prefaces
and uh the key point to understand uh
about uh the logical structure is that
there are three
main aspects of marx's concepts
of value right it's it's a complicated
concept
right and and these three aspects are
the substance
of value uh the magnitude
of value uh and the form of appearance
uh value and so i will briefly
describe each one of these
the first the substance of value right
this is the common property of
commodities
that determines their exchange values
with other commodities
which marks of course assumed to be the
abstract labor
uh required to produce commodities uh so
that's the substance
of value the common property that
determines
the exchange values right then the
magnitude
of value is quantitative right the the
the quantity
of the substance of value uh uh
required to produce commodities the
quantity of abstract labor
uh required contained in commodities
which marx called
the socially necessary labor time
uh contained in commodity
right so substance magnitude then the
form of appearance
uh of value uh the money and prices the
the observable phenomena
right uh the substance and magnitude of
value
are not directly observable as such uh
in units of abstract label therefore
commodities require an observable
form of appearance uh so that the
magnitude of each commodity can be
compared and equated
with the magnitudes of value of all
other commodities
and this observable form of appearance
uh
is uh ultimately derived as money uh and
and money prices
um sections one and two of chapter one
are about the substance and magnitude of
value section one's the most important
the title is
the title of section one is substance of
value the subtitle
substance of value magnitude of that
section three is about the form of
appearance
or value uh its title is the value form
or exchange value the point i want to
emphasize
is that there is a strict causal
relation
between these three aspects
of value causal relation is that
the substance and the magnitude of value
are
derived and presupposed in
section one one and two and then the
form of appearance of value
is derived from the substance and
magnitude of value
in volume three so i think it really
helps
to understand this overall logical
structure and then the whole
uh chapter i think becomes more
intelligible
and perhaps less of a fatiguing climb
excuse me uh my voice is what it used to
be
maintain
okay so then one more uh kind of
introduction uh just to kind of
preview and identify uh four
important controversial issues
uh involved in in in in chapter one
uh in the interpretation of chapter one
uh so the first issue is uh in section
one
uh marx's derivation of abstract labor
uh as the substance of value as the
common property
of commodities that determines their
uh exchange values and the issue is
what's the logic
of this derivation and is the derivation
value acceptable
second issue uh with respect to the
magnitude of value uh defined in volume
one
is this magnitude of value a property of
each single individual commodity
uh or is the magnitude of value
a property of multiple commodities
possessed jointly together
actually uh i learned from an email from
mikhail yesterday
uh that perhaps we don't disagree as
much as i previously
thought about that uh and so i'm
i'm i'm happy happy about that and will
not
concentrate on that as much third issue
uh and this is really i think the most
important issue both
between mchale and myself and uh the
general marxian scholarship
uh is the magnitude of value determined
uh entirely in production
the production process or uh
does it also depend at least in part on
circulation
and demand for a particular product
and then fourthly just the derivation in
section three
of money and prices as the necessary
form of appearance
of value and and for me the main issue
here is that this
uh very important section is often
uh overlooked or not not discussed
uh in any depth and i think
it's uh important in part in large part
because of its difficulty and it
seems it's so boring and detailed but uh
it's very important
as as we shall see so
uh i will uh now uh review uh
kind of section by section
uh uh my interpretation
of of of chapter one um
and with substantial textual references
uh and then i will uh discuss uh
at least one aspect in particular of uh
mikhail's
uh uh interpretation this this third
issue
of is the the determination of the
magnitude of value in production and or
exchange
okay so uh section one
uh the the substance of value abstract
labor
the magnitude of value socially
necessary labor time
section one begins with an analysis of a
commodity as a general system of
commodity exchange
uh and this general system is assumed to
be
mutually uh consistent you know
a is equal to b and b is equal to c and
a is equal to c
uh and and this property of mutual
consistency implies that commodities
are treated objectively as equivalents
exchange is the exchange of equivalence
each each commodity
is in principle uh equivalent with all
other commodities
uh and this relation of equivalence
uh in turn implies that each commodity
must possess some common property
and possess this common property
indefinite quantities
that determine the ratios in which
commodities are equivalents with one
another
marx discussed an example of a relation
of equality between
two commodities the famous corn and iron
example uh which he expressed in terms
of an equation
right it emphasizes the the
the uh the the uh the the
relation of equality between uh
commodities
mark says whatever their relation of
exchange may be it can always be
represented by an equation
right in which a given quantity of chord
is equated with some quantity
uh of a of iron so what does this
equation signify
marx says it signifies that a common
element
of identical magnitude exists
in both of these things in the
two-dimensions
so and marx of course argued that this
common property
of commodities that determines their
exchange values
is abstract labor uh the substance of
value
marx summarized his derivation of
abstract labor
as the substance of value in the
following key passage so let us look at
the residue
of the products of labor there's so
we're looking at a commodity here
considered within a a system of general
commodity exchange
right so what what what do we see well
we don't really see
anything but we know we now understand
uh that there is nothing left of them uh
but uh what he calls a phantom-like
objectivity
they are merely congealed quantities of
homogeneous humanly all these things
now tell us as we observe tell us is
that human labor power
has been expended to produce them human
labor
is accumulated in them as crystals of
this social substance which is common to
them all they are values
so uh marx described as we see
the substance of value as a phantom-like
objectivity
because this abstract labor contained in
commodities
is not directly observable as such it
exists
it's contained within commodities but
it's not something we can
observe and we will come back to this
point uh
in section three
so marx's derivation then
of abstract labor as the substance of
value can
consist of the following steps each
commodity is considered to be an equal
an equivalent to all of the commodities
the relation of equality implies that
all commodities possess
a common property right and this common
property is abstract
so that's the the the bare bones of the
derivation
uh in section one
in the next paragraph after this summary
mark's preview his later derivation of
section 3 on money as the necessary form
of appearance
of this substance of value abstract
labor
and he noted uh marx noted
in this preview we must first however we
must first consider the nature of value
independently
of its form of appearance so of course
we're just going to consider the
commodity
in terms of abstract labor and socially
necessary labor time
independently of money and prices
and he says the progress of our
investigation
will bring us back to exchange value as
the necessary mode of expression
form of appearance of value for the
present however
we must first consider the nature of
value
independently of its form of appearance
and also uh independently of any actual
act of exchange
because we're just observing this
commodity and its properties
on the on the next page the marks define
the magnitude
of value in units of labor time hours
days
independently of its form of appearance
in terms of money uh the quantity
uh the magnitude of value is measured by
its duration
labor time uh in a particular scale of
hours or days
and mars clarified that the hours of
labor time
that constitute the magnitude of value
are not measured by actual hours of
concrete labor
which would be observable but are
instead measured in terms of a social
average
quantities of labor or what he calls
socially necessary labor time
required to produce commodities his
definition
in a sentence socially necessary labor
time
is the labor time required to produce
any use value
under the conditions of production
normal for a given society
and with the average degree of skill and
intensity
of labor prevalent in that society so
uh the magnitude of value is a social
average
not any uh particular individual
of labor and then in the next paragraph
mark summarized very clearly what
exclusively determines
the magnitude of the value of any
article
is therefore the amount of labor
socially necessary
uh the labor time socially necessary for
its production
so one other important point in section
one that i
i didn't mention in my paper is that
socially necessary labor time mark says
varies
inversely with the productivity of labor
with the quantity of a product produced
per hour
abstract label and i will come back to
this point uh later as well
so toward the end of section one look
thinking again about this
overall logical structure and the three
aspects of value
uh toward the end uh mark summarizes the
argument thus far
in another preview of section three and
the form of appearance
uh with the following uh summary
of the logical structure of chapter one
he says now we know the substance of
value
right it is labor we know the measure of
his magnitude
uh it is labor time uh uh the form
which stamps value as exchange value uh
remains to be
analyzed but before we before this
we need to develop the characteristics
we have already found
more fully so develop the substance and
magnitude
uh more fully uh
in terms of labor time in terms of uh
abstract labor and socially necessary
labor time before we go on
to the form of appearance uh of value in
section three so
i think uh marx is emphasizing this
logical structure
um uh which uh i think uh uh
is very important
okay just a word about section two which
further develops the substance and
magnitude of value
prior to money and prices uh he and he
he uh further clarifies that the precise
meaning
of the magnitude of value and socially
necessary labor time
uh in units of uh
of of of uh hours or days
uh is uh he he clarifies the assumption
about different skills
and how he treats skilled labor he
states that the basic
unit of measure of socially necessary
labor time is simple unskilled labor
without special development
uh and that then skilled labor is
treated in the following way
one hour of skilled labor is assumed to
count
in the determination of the magnitude of
value as
some multiple coefficient of
one hour of simple unskilled labor
remarks put it
more complex labor counts as intensify
or rather multiply simple labor
so that a smaller quantity of complex
labor
is considered equal to a larger quantity
of
simple name right and and and this
reduction
uh is uh uh assumed to have taken place
here in
section two right uh prior to
the uh derivation of uh
money in the form of appearance uh in
section three
then there's section three again uh
a section that's uh uh often overlooked
but uh is very important because it
uh links the inner hidden essence of
value with the observable forms of
appearance it's it's actually
one of my favorite sections that so much
blood sweat and tears uh that i have
uh come to appreciate it's it's
significant
um so uh uh as i mentioned the logic
in section three is a continuation
of the logic in sections one and two uh
we have already seen that marx
explicitly noted
in section one that this logic this this
logical continuity between the sections
so as previewed in section one section
three derives money
uh as the necessary form of appearance
of the substance and magnitude of value
in sections one and two and very briefly
summarize
marx's argument in section three uh
is uh as follows the necessity of money
arises from the fact that the substance
and magnitude of value
are not directly observable as such in
units of labor time
as already mentioned so this is what
marx meant
in section one by phantom-like
objectivity means not observable
therefore uh the the question addressed
in section three
is the following how do the presupposed
unobservable quantities of socially
necessary labor time contained in
commodities as previously derived
how does uh socially necessary labor
time acquire
an objective observable form of
appearance
so that the value of each commodity can
in fact
in practice be compared with the value
of
all other commodities that's the subject
that marx promised
twice in subject one to return to as we
have seen
and the progress of marx's investigation
has indeed led back to exchange value
as the necessary form of appearance of
the substance and magnitude
of value marx posed his question
uh uh in section three uh uh
in the introduction to section three as
follows he says not and
adam of matter enters into the
objectivity of commodities
uh as values it is in
in in this sense the direct opposite of
coarsely
sensuous objectivities as physical
objects
it says we may twit we're we're
analyzing this commodity this
representative commodity right and he
said
we may twist and turn this commodity as
we wish
right it remains impossible to grasp it
remains impossible to observe it
as a thing possessing value
so then marx's general answer in section
three to
this uh uh important question of how
observe unobservable quantities of
abstract labor
obtains an observable form of appearance
is that the quantity of abstract labor
or socially necessary labor time
in any given commodity is objectively
expressed
in terms of the physical quantity of
another commodity
the equivalent commodity uh and
ultimately the money commodity
and this equivalent commodity is equal
to the given commodity
uh because it contains the same quantity
of socially necessary labor time so by
equating
these two commodities that have the same
quantity of labor time
the the the magnitude substance and
magnitude of value in the first
commodity is expressed
in terms of the physical quantity of the
equivalent commodity
that contains uh the same quantity of
labor time
mark says uh we started
uh from exchange value uh
or the exchange relation of commodities
in order to track down
the value that lay hidden
unobservable within it we must now
return
to this form of appearance and value so
the logic
is from uh the hidden uh
to the observable from the observable
uh the observable form of appearance is
derived from
the hidden uh substance and magnitude
of value and perhaps the clearest
evidence uh that section three presumes
that each commodity contains a definite
quantity of abstract labor
and that these presumed quantities of
abstract labor are used to provide a
quantitative labor theory of exchange
value is one subsection in particular
uh of the simple form of value that is
entitled
the quantitative determinancy of the
relative form of a value
uh ages 144 to 146
in the penguin edition
uh a very important and often overlooked
uh uh subsection
in this subsection marx emphasized that
the abstract labor contained in
commodities
is presupposed and it must be expressed
not only
in qualitative terms as the same kind of
homogeneous human labor
but also must be expressed in
quantitative terms as a definite
quantity
of magnitude of value uh
contained in commodities so socially
necessary labor time is a quantity
and therefore its objective form of
appearance
must also be quantity
so in this subsection it is clearly and
explicitly assumed
that any commodity says contains a
definite quantity of human labor
that's the presupposition the equality
of linen and coats
mark says presupposes the presence
of exactly as much of the substance of
value
or the same quantity of labor time in
the two commodities
this subsection also discusses how the
the the quantitative expression of of
the linen
in terms of uh the exchange value
uh in with coats changes
the quantitative expression of the value
of the linen
in terms of the quantity of coats this
quantitative ratio
changes if the labor time in either the
quantity
in either the linen or the code changes
so the presupposed quantities of labor
time change
marks discusses four cases right
first the labor time required to produce
the linen changes
then the labor time required to produce
the code changes and then both together
and then in different directions
uh but uh in each case the uh
the labor time contained in the
commodities is presupposed and that then
determines
the exchange ratios so i have an
extensive
excerpt from this subsection in my paper
uh and i will come back to this later as
as well but the basic logic i think is
very clear from the presupposed labor
times
in production to exchange values in
exchange
uh so uh these conclusions with respect
this is in a subsection of the
the simple form of value uh but
the same uh conclusions
apply as well uh to the expanded form of
value the general form of value
and ultimately the the the money form of
value and money prices money prices are
determined by
relative quantities of labor time in
production and changes
in exchange values are determined by
changes in these
relative quantities of labor time
required to produce a given commodity
and the equivalent
in subsection c of section three
on the general form of value uh is
defined in terms of uh equations
to emphasize the the uh the
relation of equality between the
relative and the
equivalent uh forms one code sequence
with 20
yards of willetta linen or 10 pounds of
tea is equal to 20 pounds of linen now
40 pounds of cotton is equal to 20
pounds a minute
etc right so all these equations
presuppose that the two commodities on
either side of the equation
contain the same property and contain an
equal magnitude
of the same commodity that's what an
equation means and uh
uh marx emphasized again uh in this
section that
the general form of value is not only
quality
and it's not only an expression of
uh abstract labor as a common property
but
of that this expression of value
is uh uh quantitative right and and
expresses
uh uh says in this general form of value
when all commodities are counted now
finally as comparable uh with the linen
all commodities appear not only as
qualitatively equal
as value in general but also as values
of
quantitatively comparable magnitudes
so section d of uh
subsection d of section three is
entitled the money
form of value uh and in this subsection
uh the price of a commodity is defined
as the exchange
value of a given commodity with the
money commodity
and this price is determined as before
by the relative quantities of labor time
presupposed to be contained in the given
commodity
and the money commodity so the price of
a commodity
in terms of gold is the quantity of gold
right a physical quantity a quantity of
gold that contains the same amount of
labor time
as the given commodity whose price is
being determined
and here there's another set of
equations uh
similar to the equations for the general
form of value
except that the equivalent commodity is
gold
rather than linen so there's a gold
price
for each and every other commodity which
of course presumes
that gold and each of the other
commodities
uh contain the same quantity uh socially
necessary
then in the first edition of volume one
uh unfortunately not in late marx
concluded uh his derivation of money and
prices as the necessary form of
appearance of value
by emphasizing once again uh
the overall logical structure here uh
and that the form of value what he says
arises
out of or is derived from
uh the substance uh and the magnitude of
value
but mark says what was decisively
important
was to discover the inner necessary
connection
between value form
value substance and value amount
right and expressed conceptually he says
to prove
that the value form arises out of
the value concept right
so uh i i think these many passages in
chapter one uh
provide very strong unambiguous textual
evidence to support the interpretation
interpretation that chapter one
presupposes that individual commodities
contain definite quantities of socially
necessary labor time as derived in
sections one and two
and then section three derives money
prices as the necessary form of
appearance
of these quantities of presupposed
quantities
of abstract labor that's the inner
necessary
connection between sections one and two
and three
of chapter one and that's the overall
logical structure
of marx's labor era of value and money
and abstract prices
uh in chapter one
okay how am i doing in time you're doing
great
okay so then uh i'll take the time i
have left
uh just to discuss this most important
aspect uh
uh or at least difference of
interpretation between michelle and
myself
uh and and i will suggest uh
a possibility perhaps uh for some
maybe less of a disagreement uh uh
we shall see uh and and that issue
uh has to do with the determination of
the magnitude of value
right and is the magnitude of value
socially necessary labor time is that
determined
uh entirely uh in production
uh are also at least in part in exchange
and depends on
uh the demand on the market
for individual commodities so this is
really one of the most controversial
issues
among marxian economists in general in
recent decades
mchale's interpretation as i understand
it comes out of the new marx reading
in germany which has evolved in the rest
of the world
uh in in terms of value form
the so-called value form interpretation
of marx's theory and this
so-called value form interpretation has
become popular
in recent decades and its proponents
argue that socially necessary
labor time is not determined solely by
average labor time in production
but also depends in part on social
demand on the market
and mikhail is uh a prominent
uh uh proponent of this value form
interpretation mikhail wrote
in the introduction in his introduction
to
capital books uh labor time expended in
production
as well as for the satisfaction of
monetary social demand
constitutes ballot so turning the
sentence around the
value is constituted both by
uh the labor expended in production and
the satisfaction of monetary demand
so first i want to review again some of
the main passages in chapter one
that support my interpretation uh that
socially necessary labor time
is determined uh by production
could i interrupt you for a sec yeah i
just want to ask a question
that might open up this disagreement or
almost agreement to everyone who's
joining us what would you say the stakes
are
of your interpretation his
interpretation
and the disagreement what's at stake
there really
aside from the the proofs one way or the
other
well uh i think uh first of all just
being uh what uh i'm trying to be
as uh you know uh
uh a true as possible to marx's text
uh and and that uh
uh in itself is is uh uh
a first objective i i also think it you
know eventually uh
the uh the differences have to do
with uh whether uh
uh uh marx's theory is a theory
of uh at least in part
uh uh of equilibrium prices
right uh are uh non-equilibrium prices
and what's the relative importance
uh uh and and that's that's also been a
kind of separate discussion
going on uh in
marxian scholarship uh for for
uh a long time right but what i think is
not
uh very clearly and widely recognized
and including
uh by myself until really working on
this paper
right is the connection between those
two issues so as
this marx's theory about kind of you
know
well i mean i would say marxist theory
is mainly about surplus value
right but then equilibrium prices are
uh assumed uh in order and explained
in order ultimately not to explain
equilibrium prices but to explain
surplus value
and how does it how does it change our
understanding of surplus value
to think that value is
created and gets its magnitude
in the production process with no
additional
inputs okay the uh the
marx's theory of surplus value uh the
inner law
as he called it surplus value is
determined by surplus labor
right surplus labor in production
uh and uh uh
a clear uh strong uh conclusion of
uh exploitation right uh
but uh if so if surplus value
also depends on the market
right on demand uh that
is uh uh what mark's called a
distracting influence
right uh and and uh
uh is is uh a less uh strong
uh theory of the the inner law of
surplus value and
and exports it it brings in
uh uh uh distractions
right right that's very helpful i
appreciate it i know that line of
thinking to some degree that
if value is all created in production
then it it strengthens
the revolutionary position of the
proletariat
or makes exploitation
a graver issue or a more emphatic
problem in capital so i appreciate your
you're clarifying that
okay and we can come back derail your
presentation so you're welcome to go on
with it
uh okay thank you uh
uh so uh let me just review a few
of the the key quotations so we'll have
of
my interpretation as we saw mark's
defined
socially necessary labor time as the
labor time required to produce
any use value under the conditions of
production
normal for a given society and with the
average degree of skill and intensity of
labor
prevalent in that society the next
paragraph mark summarized
what exclusively determines
the magnitude and value of any article
is therefore the labor time
socially necessary for its production
right so nothing is said here about
exchange
and demand uh what exclusively
determines
socially necessary labor time is the
average labor time
in production and uh coming back to the
the issue of the inverse relationship
between the magnitude of value and the
productivity of labor
toward the end of section one of marx
discussed this relationship
and he said the value of a commodity
would therefore remain constant
if the value would remain constant
if the labor time required for its
production
also remain constant right so even
though supply and demand may be changing
around
all over the place right if the uh
quantity required for its production
is constant the value is constant right
but the latter changes the the
productivity change
changes within well value changes with
every variation in the productivity of
labor
and he says the productivity of labor is
determined by various circumstances
the average amount of skill of the
workman uh the state of science the
degree of its practical application the
social organization of production
the extent and capabilities of the means
of production
by physical conditions etc right so
these are characteristics of production
that
affect uh socially necessary labor time
uh and in general the the greater the
productivity of labor the less is the
labor time required
to produce that article and the less
therefore
is the value and vice versa he says
the value of a commodity therefore
varies
inversely with the productivity of the
labor
well i also wanted to quote from that
subsection
on the quantitative determination
of the form of value
but
[Music]
i i must have misplaced that page
uh but it's again i hope you will look
at it right page
144 and five six uh
that this is uh uh the labor times are
presupposed
uh and that then determines the uh
the relative form
do you feel like there's enough evidence
on the table to rest your case
temporarily
uh yes yes yes i wanted to i also wanted
to
uh uh discuss the value form
sorry i lost my page there uh
okay so the value form interpretation
in contrast right uh argues that
uh if supply is greater than demand
uh in an industry then the price of the
commodity will fall
and uh the socially necessary labor time
will also be reduced
right because of the insufficient
uh social demand even though
uh even if the average labor time in
production remains the same
however uh and this is the point
we touched on a minute ago i argue that
marx's theory
in capital generally assumes that supply
is equal to demand
right and so uh assumes away that case
except for a few asides
uh here and there in other words marx's
theory of value in capital is not about
the daily fluctuation of market prices
but is instead
about the uh center of gravity
of those market prices the the
equilibrium prices the long run average
which are the centers of gravity around
which market prices
what's great the main question as i said
the marxist theory is to explain surplus
value
and the inner law of surplus value with
surplus labor
and to consider fluctuations due to
supply and demand
uh marx argued at the end of chapter
five would be a distraction from
discovering and pinpointing the inner
law
of surplus value so i present more
textual evidence in my paper to support
this
supplies equal to demand equilibrium
interpretation of marx's theory of value
and would be happy to discuss these
later and i think the the evidence is
uh conclusive that uh marx
is trying to explain the inner laws of
capitalism and not
the daily fluctuations of market prices
um and since equilibrium prices
uh assume supplies equal demand
then in that case supply and demand have
no effect
on the determination of equilibrium
prices they
cancel each other out equilibrium prices
are determined in that case
solely by the fundamental cause of
average labor times in production
supply and demand determine market
prices
not equilibrium prices furthermore
if supply is not equal to demand in an
industry which is usually the case
the market price of the commodity will
be different
from the equilibrium price but the
equilibrium price will
nonetheless remain the same right and
will still be determined by the average
labor time in production
even though supply and demand are not
equal and market prices are fluctuating
around
the equilibrium price equilibrium price
will change
only if the average labor time in
production
changes uh one more page uh
mikhail uh wrote in his book that
socially necessary labor time is
determined by three
reductions and this was actually very
helpful to me
uh one reduction of unequal
productivities of labor to average
productivity uh within each industry two
the reduction of skilled labor to
unskilled labor
in all industries and three the
reduction of supply
to demand right so however
if it is assumed that supply is equal to
demand
then mikhail's reduction number three
of supply to demand is nullified plays
no wrong
right and in this case socially
necessary labor time
is determined by the first two
reductions
unequal productivities to average
productivity skill labor to unskilled
labor
right and these two remaining reductions
are characteristics of production
and determinants of labor time in
production thus if it is assumed
uh that supplies equal to demand as marx
generally assumed in capital
then demand and exchange have no effect
on the determination of socially
necessary labor time
even with black hills interpretation
of socially necessary labor time because
the
uh supply is assumed to be equal to
demand and
that uh reduction
uh is not necessary so i hope
mikhail will agree that under the
assumption of supply is equal to demand
at least supply socially necessary labor
time depends only on the
average labor time in production
and if socially if supply is not equal
to demand
then we have i think two different
interpretations
of socially necessary labor time which
may in fact
begin be compatible
be mutually compatible and not mutually
exclusive they apply to different cases
right uh uh
one an equilibrium concept of socially
necessary labor time
uh uh determined by average labor time
in production and independent of demand
because you're assuming that away
right and secondly a disequilibrium
concept of socially necessary labor time
labor time received through exchange
right uh which also uh depends on
impart and demand and it has occurred to
me
in recent weeks while working on this
paper that
maybe we agree uh on this point
uh more than i thought right
uh in in the case of supplies
demand i hope we can agree that socially
necessary labor time is the average
labor time in production
which determines the equilibrium price
right if so then the the disagreement
would really boil down to
uh in the case of supply not equal to
demand
uh what's the definition of socially
necessary labor time and is
uh uh uh uh the concept uh
uh uh operative uh uh at all
um and it seems to me that uh
maybe these these two definitions i i
don't think mark's ever talked about
this
uh explicitly in terms of socially
necessary labor time anyway but
i i i want to search some more
and and think some more about this uh
that the the the equilibrium and the
disequilibrium concepts of
socially necessary labor time uh may be
uh uh mutually uh uh
uh compatible and i i think this would
be
uh uh uh a significant
uh agreement and as i said michael's
discussion of the three
reductions uh one of which is the
reduction of supply demand i
i think helped me realize at least this
possibility
of more of uh uh
agreement if social supply is equal to
demand then there are only two
reductions
uh both of which have to do with the
labor time
uh reduction so i'll stop here for now
and give mikhail
a chance to respond and see what other
people had to say
and uh thank you very much for your
attention and i look forward to the
discussion
thank you fred let's just take a minute
to thank fred for his talk before we
get into the beautiful family fight
there's no better fights than family
fights
and especially when they're about
scripture it turns out
all sorts of hermeneutic questions are
on the table now too so
i think what sort of what questions
hermeneutic questions
okay yeah but thank you very much for
your presentation
i think mikhail you'd like to respond
and you could take as much time as you
want to do that
um this is dangerous when you allow me
this to take as much time as i want
i try to make it briefly
um but first is is the connection okay
can
can you understand me okay so
first i have to thank uh fred that he
changed his uh original idea of a paper
and make such
uh big efforts to to discuss
my uh approach to um value theory
i think um this is a very big
appreciation of my work and
i'm i'm very thankful for that
that you have main critical points um
is not bad because i think in this point
we will
agree that critique is the method to
to get progress nothing is final nothing
is perfect so
we need critique and i i appreciate
your your critique on my points and
already in
in this um short exchange we had the
last days
i learned a lot and i maybe we
will not come to an agreement but at
least
also for me it became clearer
in which points i have to argue
more precise more
more exact and this i learned by you
so i want to focus on
the main um
point we disagree is the magnitude
of value already determined
by production before the exchange
process
or is the magnitude of value
of value not determined by production
alone and in so far also not before
the exchange process already one person
asked before what is on stake what are
the consequences of these different
interpretations and
i think he not fred the the person who
who asked had came to the
conclusion okay it strengthens
revolutionary when everything is
rested in production i think this is
rather independent from any um
revolutionary activities or from
insights which lead to to revolution but
there is something
on stake when everything already
is determined by production
then at least in principle
we can know everything we can know
all the magnitude of value
we can treat value not as an
outcome which emerges like
marx says in the back of the producers
but we can treat them as
known uh amounts and exactly this
in in soviet union in the so-called real
socialism planning economy was attempted
there was the theory of they called it
the conscious application of the law of
value
and this conscious application exactly
presupposed that we know
already by production without an process
of exchange
what are the magnitudes of value and
this planning process
was an enormous failure so
for for this the wrong theory they had
and of course not only this was wrong i
i don't want to to reduce all the
failure
failure of soviet union to this single
point but this point
also contributed to this it had some
revival some years ago in the
discussions
of a socialism of the 21st
century then for example
authors like paul cockshot argued by the
use of computer now we have the
technology
to to make use of all this knowledge and
we can um use
this knowledge we have from the
production process of commodity
production
um for a socialist system i think
this is totally wrong and
when you try to do a socialist system
according to such assumptions
um it will be disastrous so indeed
there is something on stake it's not
only a question of details
or pure pure signs it has
political consequences
mikhail can i ask you just on this point
it seemed to me that fred was saying
that as a manifestation of value
exchange value allows you to know
what's determined in production do you
mean that
when you say you can't treat them as
known amounts
the magnitudes of value do you mean that
they're actually being determined in
exchange
or they're just coming to be known in
exchange i think there's a difference
between being determined and being known
exactly it is a difference and they
are they not come in
to be known before exchange
we they are not determined they
are as fred quoted me correctly
they are determined by production
and circulation or production and
exchange production alone is not
enough to determine magnitude of value
and it is not a question of knowledge i
will explain this
at once let me just do before
one remark about different levels of
discussion
we can discuss this question
where magnitude of value is
determined on a heminoitical
level interpreting marks texts
what is the opinion of marks but also
we have to to discuss what is the
reality
of commodity production and commodity
exchange and in so far the hermeneutical
level is only a helper when we
assume that marx did a very good
analysis so we must be clear about his
analysis but the
point which is decisive
is our analysis then of
reality and not the analysis of
texts of mark so i i think we have to
distinguish
these two levels i will come briefly
to the level of reality
i i as i take this as an abbreviation
why do i think that magnitude of value
is not determined only by production
just let us restrict to these two
determinations we agree social
socially necessary labor time
and the reduction of complex labor
to simple labor socially
necessary labor time is a kind of
average there are different kinds of
production processes as marx discusses
this in
chapter one the one producer
is quicker the other is slower
but what contributes to this um
average is not just what every producer
is doing
it contributes only that
products which are brought to the market
when there is a super modern factory
with an extremely high productivity
but the products are hindered to enter
the market
or the owner of the factory decides to
sell these products abroad because he
can receive higher prices or whatever
then this factory
or the the labor in this factory will
not
contribute to this average
socially necessary labor time so by
looking only on the production side
we don't know really what contributes
to the um to this average
and even more clear it becomes
when we look to the reduction
of complex labor to simple labor
it is not only one reduction you have
a lot of different kinds of complex
labor
all of them must be reduced to simple
labor
let us say one
hour of labor of a craftsman is reduced
to
three hours of simple labor five hours
labor of a one hour labor of an
engineer is reduced to five hours
of simple labor but where does this
reduction come from
is it determined by production i don't
know
not even a theory who explains this
reduction
by by production itself mark speaks of a
social process in the second
sub-section of chapter one and in
chapter
seven in the last footnote of this
chapter
he stresses that this
reduction also depends
of um social prejudice for example
that it comes out in a in a historical
process
and we have um very striking examples
that for example the
such branches of work
where women dominate as workers
usually such branches count
less in this reduction it is not
a question of the pure complexity of
labor or of the production process
it is also a part of
social evaluation and this is beyond
the production process in so far
in sofa um i think it is
impossible to
determine the magnitude of value
only by production i don't want to go
deep in the question of demand
and supply which has
i think nothing to do with the two
points i just
mentioned but i want to to stress one
point it is true that marx
later in capital says i presuppose
demand and supply equals
and by this he can abstract from a lot
of problems
but what is the demand and the supply
which equals how is demand and supply
determined this we must
discuss before we can assume
supply and demand equals and i think
what
marx is doing in the third chapter is
a second he gives a second meaning to
socially
necessary labor time and this
second meaning then defines
what is demand and only then we can
discuss or we can
presuppose uh demand and supply is
we assume that it is equal but okay this
is another point
now um i want
shortly to come to the hermeneutical
level
what is marx telling us
i think indeed we have to look to the
logic
of mark's argumentation
as fred also stressed
i would say we have to be clear what in
the first
three chapters marx is doing
what is the object what he what marx
wants to
to research in the first three chapters
of volume one
i think it is commodity circulation
this complicated process of commodity
circulation commodity against money
money against commodity commodity
against money and so on this permanent
intersection
is reduced by marx in a first
step of abstraction to the exchange
process commodity owners exchange
commodities and the core of the analysis
of this exchange
process is the exchange
relation which marx analyzes
in chapter one so
when we read capital we do the
the journey backwards we start with the
most
abstract core the exchange relation of
two commodities
in chapter two we include the commodity
owners
we come to the production to the
exchange process
and in chapter three we
see the intersection and interference
of all the exchange processes
in the circulation
in the commodity circulation
so exchange sorry my
my voice is not in a good condition
at the moment so what marx
analyzes as exchange relation
is the most abstract core of
the circulation process of commodities
and this exchange relation
he dissects like an
anatom an anatomist
fred gave the nice
quote where mark says we have to
consider
value independently from
i think it's form of appearance or value
form
i stress that marx wrote we
have to consider he doesn't say value
value exists independently from value
form
he says we have to consider it and
so i think marx behaves like an
anatomist who wants to analyze the human
body
and he has to start with certain organs
so maybe he starts with the heart which
is pumping blood
and then comes to the lung which feeling
is filling the the blood with oxygen
but this sequence of explanation
is not identical with a sequence
of existence that first the heart
exists and then after a while
the lung exists and then after a while
something else exists so
what i think is an um
a mistake of threat is to
identify the sequence
of explanation we find in marx
with a sequence of
existence a sequence
in time and also i think it's a mistake
to see in this sequence of time
a causal relationship
a causality from the
what he thinks is first to that
what he thinks comes later
at the beginning of his paper he gives
this nice quote
from the first edition that
mark said i wanted to prove that the
value
form arises from the value concept
this is a very hegelian wording and marx
himself said sometimes
he is cockating with hegelian
terminology here also becomes
clear that this terminology arises from
is not a temporal sequence
when you read hegel's signs of logic
you have the essence and the necessity
that the
essence needs a form of appearance
but of course hegel nowhere
argues that essence
exists first in time
and then after a while it receives
a form of appearance and i think the
same is true
for value and well you form
as form of appearance they can only
exist
simultaneously so what marx is doing in
the first
chapter he is dissecting
the exchange relation
he talks about value but value
inside the exchange relation not
outside the exchange relation
so this is one
important difference in um in the
hermeneutics in the interpretation
i will just briefly
mention another difference now
fred didn't mention it in um
in his lecture but he mentioned it in
the paper he he sent me and i suppose
also it was distributed
to um to to the audience
uh where the point is what
means the common in the phrase
that labor is the common uh
social substance of value
fred absolutely correctly quotes
my interpretation that there are two
different ways to interpret this
common common can mean that
two things independently from each other
possess a property or it can mean
that common means they
share this property
and my interpretation is the second one
they share it
and here is the point i also want to
give
some textual
evidence for my approach or the for the
approach that also
marx had in mind this meaning of common
as a shared
property inside the
the exchange relation there is a
difference
between the wording of the first edition
and the wording of the second edition
which is totally lost in the existing
english translations when you
read the first translation
either the translation of the first
edition of capital which also
fred quotes you can read
in the translation of drug drugs that
the common social substance which
merely manifests itself differently in
different use values
is labor in the second
edition you can read a very similar
sentence in the translation
of ben folks as crystals
of this social substance which is
common to them all their values
in both english english sentences we
have the word common
but in german marx changed
the words in the first edition the word
he used was
gemeinsam and for the mind's arm
kamen is a proper translation in the
second edition
marx used the word gemini
and here common is a very poor
translation
ge mindshaftly comes from the noun
ge mineshaft community
ge mineshaftly you have something
when the community has it
so that marx changed
from gemeinsam common
took a mineshaft leak in community
for me is a very clear sign
that he saw the value substance
as something which is only
existing when there is a relation
between the two commodities and this
relation
is in the exchange relation
in the exchange relation we can
say the one commodity has a magnitude of
value and the other
commodity has a magnitude of value with
this i
agree with with fret
but outside this relation
you cannot speak about magnitudes of
value
so with this i want also to
close my my answer
to fret thank you very much thank you
mikhail
we appreciate your coming back and
you're being such a good sport
and giving us a lot to think about it's
great when
we have family fights it's great when um
hermeneutic questions get opened up it's
always interesting to me
when people use the
um the geographical
move which is this is what marx was
saying and when people use the move
well even if he was saying that he might
not be right
this this these ways of looking at the
text are
different and they're both important and
they move around in different people's
readings fred i'm going to give the
microphone over to you
do you want to respond uh uh a few
responses i also want to hear from other
people
uh so uh um
start with uh the the first point about
um uh
uh the magnitude of value uh
cannot be known uh in production
uh and uh i'm not arguing
that the magnitude of value socially
necessary labor time
uh it can be known in production i
i argue that you know marx assumes that
it
exists uh in production in a system of
commodity production we're not
you know so it's produced for exchange
right so it's already in production it's
in an exchange relationship
it's in an economy based on commodity
exchange
right so i i'm certainly not saying that
uh it is known or has to be known
right i mean it exists and
my point is that i stress that that
section three is about
it's not knowable
in production it's it's not knowable in
terms of
abstract labor that's why money is
necessary
right so i i i i think
that that kind of misses my point all
together
uh that that socially necessary labor
time
it in order to it is is
exists but is unknown right is assumed
to exist
right and and in order to become known
right it has to uh uh
express its hidden value uh
in the observable form of money so i i
think
i think you are uh uh conflating
uh uh know and exist
right and and and uh i'm i'm i'm not
conflating that i'm i'm emphasizing that
that's not the case
that uh value is not known until
uh exchange until the form of appearance
is the form of appearance and
um you know i think the the
uh uh uh reference to
the the ussr is not relevant
uh because i'm not i'm not you know this
is a theory of capitalism
right and and it was attempted to be
applied in crude ways
uh uh to a planned economy but i don't
think that has anything to do
with the validity or lack thereof of
marx's theory certainly not of my
interpretation
and on simultaneity
of uh uh
[Music]
everything in in capitalism i i think
uh i think the body the body uh analogy
is not a good one uh because
uh marx is analyzing capitalism
uh within uh which which is a process
right and the process is the circuit of
capital right
and the circular capital goes through
distinct phases right capital exists
first
on the market in the form of uh money
used to purchase means of production and
labor power then
capital exists in production right
where marx says exclusively uh
capital is formed right surplus value is
produced
right and then right consecutively in
time
uh there is the return to the market and
the
the sale of the markets of the products
produced
and uh the realization of the value
produced right so and
uh you know i'm not saying that that
value is known in production
right i'm saying value is produced
production and it
and then subsequently i mean i'm not
saying that it's
you know that that simultaneous
determination is not possible
in in other cases i'm saying that
exchange value right uh
is determined by production now in that
sequence
production comes before its uh sale
right and so uh in in in that particular
case
in that particular reality there is
temporal sequence of causation
because we're talking about a process uh
a circuit um so i
i think i'll stop there for now and uh
maybe come back but uh
i'd like to hear from other people too
great so why don't we open up
the chat for questions and maybe we can
come back around to these
distinctions through people's
other people's minds there might have
been some comments earlier on but if you
want to make a comment would you put it
back in
now repost and also post your questions
okay could we go to manuel casique
herrera
um audrey would you open manuels like
manuel if you're if you're there you
could ask your question
do we have you yeah can you hear me
yes yeah i i
spent having to speak in english
in front of a whole audience so
i'm gonna try really hard to do my best
uh um
my question is like
uh is obvious
that market prices
have oscillations
and we those oscillations
if abstract private labor
is the
substance of all the value produced
and all the surplus value
is the same remain the same so
when market prices us oscillate
a capitalist can
compete each other to appropriate
surplus value produced by other
capitalists
because the the surplus value pool
remains always the same despite the
priceless oscillations
what what would you what would you think
of that
thank you manuel it was a perfect
english rendition of your question
fred do you want to respond
uh well uh capitalist would
uh i mean that that was the subject of
volume three
that is the subject of volume three the
the distribution of surplus value
right and some capitalists are able to
uh uh appropriate more surplus value
than others for
various market power reasons right
but that is uh
a subsequent division of the surplus
value
that is produced by workers
so it's it's it's it it's a part of the
theory you know it can be incorporated
in theory but it's
it's because one capitalists uh
appropriates uh more surplus value than
another
uh capitalist doesn't mean the
capitalists produce that surplus value
the total surplus value uh comes from
the surplus labor of workers and then
that's divided up
in various competitive ways
i hope that helps okay we have a
question from
bilal can we open bilals mike
bilal i'm an intrepid undergraduate in
the seminar
welcome um thank you uh thank you
professor
mosley for your interesting comments i
had a question about uh inflation in
particular
you mentioned how marxist theory
explains the inner laws of capitalism
and not
minor fluctuations but one of the inner
laws is the sustained increase in
general price level that we've seen you
know constant increase in inflation
so i was wondering whether your your
interpretation of marks maybe just
marx's writings itself sort of die in
and can explain this inner law of
capitalism or is it something that i i
don't know a lot of marxist theory
that i've seen just somehow overlooks
inflation i'm not really sure how marx
explains a lot of it
uh well that's a good uh kind of uh
contemporary question uh uh obviously
and uh you know in marx's theory
uh in uh in
capital he assumes that money is a
commodity
right some people argue money has to be
a commodity
and i don't i don't think that's true
right but uh marx's theory has to be
uh i think updated and uh
uh uh elaborated to take into account
the fact that uh money uh is is no
longer uh
uh uh a commodity like gold
right uh so uh i think that's an
important
uh current task of marching economics is
is to uh uh develop
a more uh complete uh uh
theory of non-commodity money i've
done some work on that and i don't think
it's the
uh the the final answer uh
but based on some hence mark's game
uh when there was uh uh inconvertible
uh uh fiat money in the
late 19th late 18th and early 20th
century
then if too much money is
forced into circulation then
prices will rise right so
uh that i think is uh uh at least a
starting point it's it's not
the total answer uh and it it
uh you know requires uh uh
much more development but also
a change of the basic function of a
definition of the the what money is
in capitalism today
okay thank you i'm going to read a
question from the chat from ann lee
summers
is the disagreement in forming the
surplus value problem
actually related to
appearance about the nature of physical
labor versus cognitive labor
and the formation of a commodity's
socially necessary labor time and hence
its labor power
does value form analysis solve that
problem
also doesn't this also resemble resemble
the later historical issue of monopoly
capital unaddressed by marx but taken on
by baron
and sweesy doesn't this also allow for
the kinds of issues brought up by
analytic marxism in terms of
inequality of distribution referring to
rumor
so the first question is
[Music]
about the difference between physical
and
cognitive labor in
i guess the calculation of the magnitude
or the creation
of the commodities value and the second
is about um
well the i think the the question about
monopoly capital is
uh in my view much easier to answer uh
and again i think that was related to
the previous question that
uh uh uh uh monopoly
uh affects the distribution of surplus
in my view interpretation of marx's
theory
monopolies affect the distribution of
surplus value
uh but unless that's affecting wages in
some way
uh does not uh affect the the the
production of surplus value and the
the total amount of surplus value that's
produced
right so yeah this uh this
i would disagree with moran and swedes
right they
they thought monopoly capital actually
increased
surplus value right but uh
i think a more consistent interpretation
would be that
uh monopolies uh get a bigger share
of the total surplus value but in
general
except maybe on a small scale do not
affect the
production and the total amount
over time as well monopolies have to
cede their monopoly
at a certain point right it's a
temporarily
bounded problem monopoly
uh yeah it's you know it's one aspect
of the competition
and
[Music]
competition has to do with determines
the
the distribution of surplus value and
that will
certainly change over time uh
the the cognitive question i think is
another challenge
i think that's uh i think
it it uh
you know obviously is uh uh value
producing
uh and so i mean this would be
one one uh example of skills
labor uh and so uh
the cognitive labor would produce uh
in an hour more value uh
how much more value we don't know
but uh that that that is what
what you know what uh marx's theory
would suggest
uh but uh
and then you know then the question is
how
you know how uh
important is it to know
these reduction coefficients
and i think it is some importance but i
mean mark said at the end of chapter
seven is theory of surplus value
you know this even though he didn't
present any theory of what return what
determines those
reduction coefficients so to speak he
said the same theory applies
to skilling right that skill labor is
paid more
right but they're also produced value at
uh at a higher rate and and
therefore the basic theory of surplus
value still applies
and i think that would also apply to
cognitive
okay i want to invite anyone else
in the listenership watchers viewership
to
pose some questions while you're doing
that i will i want to go back to
something that mikhail brought up that
that
needs a lot more exposition and i know
maybe he's done it elsewhere but i want
to ask you fred about
his proposition that in fact
exchange enters into the constitution of
socially necessary labor time
that is products that are produced and
not realized in exchange
don't get counted in the average so this
is a back door way in
that doesn't have anything to do with
the supply demand problem
what do you think about that uh well i
think we're
the the theory assumes a system in which
what is produced is
exchange you know uh we're looking at a
at a totality with
you know if in in that case uh
the the the the
the company that that sells elsewhere
right in another market would not be
included in the
determination of socially necessary
labor time it's not a
purely physical thing that you you know
in any country you
do a weighted average of the labor times
and determine socially necessary labor
time
it's goods that were produced for this
market
and and that they're the only ones that
go
into the the average i don't
see a problem there
it looks like there aren't any other
questions we want to thank you for your
presentation
invite you to not sign off while we let
everyone else go
let them thank you for coming and
presenting
really important material so thank you
thank you
thank you also it was nice to meet fred
again thanks for your comments as always
and we will be in touch i'm sure
thank you michael